hello everyone i'm grand master
dennis borsch and this is insane
in the end game not as insane
as an alireza first game
it's actually a little bit more calmer
than that
last drama more richard reity
so the topic of today is a bit of
richard reity
richard trey t is actually a player
sort of undeservedly untalked about
or not talked about rather even though
he was kind of the player inventing
all these hyper modern openings and
for that purpose i am going to show you
a couple of things
in the opening now of course there's
plenty of ratey systems
one of the ratey systems is b3
i actually worked out a repertoire
for this as white which is a very
interesting move
d5 bishop b2 and you might sacrifice
a pawn for good compensation
but that's really beside the point it
just again
shows how influential reity really
is the other point that's actually
interesting and
what shows why he is
so important he was the first player to
actually identify that you don't have to
have pieces on the board
i mean you don't have to have
directly occupying those center squares
if you can control the squares and
this plan of b3 bishop b2 is
original in this sense that he's not
trying to actually get
pawns there he's just trying to put
pressure on them
similarly enough um
is the knight f3 d5 g3 idea which is the
rati
white is planning to put pressure on the
e5 square
and put pressure on the d5 pawn
with side moves again merely controlling
those squares
and not really trying to occupy
it
so i see chad saying yeah but i think
his best contributions were masters of
the chess board and all of his puzzles
well it's one thing that
he was great with his puzzles those are
actually
quite amazing and in fact you
can see from his games that he has a
tactical vision like
not many and sadly because
he didn't have like a full career in his
uh
time and in his prime he couldn't quite
show
how talented he is just like
breyer he really didn't get a shot to
show more that they were capable of
like i think one of those players really
under-appreciated is richard ratey
thankfully recently the ratio opening
has been
really good and really popular so his
name
still is ringing bell for others
so i see the message by exquisite
i played through 50 or so of his games a
few years ago as a real genius it's a
shame how little known he
is i'm glad
boros is such a fan yes um
i've known couple of his games and if
you haven't checked out his king's
gambit part
and his kings gambit games it's
something you should
because if you check those out
you'll understand why magnus carlsen
plays
some certain sub-lines of the king's
gambit
himself well because it was sort of
influenced by richard ratey
and reity was unique the way he kind of
approached his game like his whole
hyper-modern chess
is different from the times he was at
and
in but okay um
this game that we're going to take a
look at is between rudolph spillman
and richard ratey and we're going to
take a look at how richard ratey handles
the hanging
e4 e5 not f3
knight c6 bishop b5 knight f6
and we all have that impression that the
berlin wasn't really played
until like the 2000s when
kasparov and kramnik played their match
but actually was pretty popular even
earlier than that
this is played in the early 1900s
which might surprise some of you
castles knight e4 d4
but instead of the now topical knight d6
and this ending
which leads to the berlin game
originally everybody played bishop e7
which is actually a move
more or less playable there is nothing
wrong with this one
but of course knight d6 after that world
championship match in london
superseded this idea
yeah um manny is correct rudolph
spielman
was a very strong tactical player and
this again this opening choice shows
that richard ratey
is a shrewd psycholo psychologist
as well
i takes e5 i take c5 castles
not the most aggressive way of playing
not gonna delve too deep in had to play
this
opening but it is definitely queen e2
that has to be
tried in this type of position
immediately
pressing down the center knight takes e5
is
a little bit inaccurate and sort of
leads into
exchanges queen e2 d5 now
e takes d6 would be played or could be
played
if this was more of
um well more of like a round robin event
where white is considered like
is happy with a draw but in this game as
we all know rudolph spielman
is an aggressive player so he's not that
interested
in exchanges instead goes for c6 c c4
c6 c takes d5 and again
now look at that this is a game from
1910 yet
we see splendid combinations c takes b5
would run into queen takes e4
which is nothing good
but of course reity takes with the queen
bishop d3 bishop f5
queen f3 rook d8 bishop takes
e4 now
we get something very similar to a
berlin end game
but also somewhat resembling
slav slash queen's gambit accepted
positions
so queen takes c4 bishop takes c4
wouldn't be that great
because of queen g3 and there's pressure
on this king
there's this idea of bishop h6 and
knight c3
and in all cases um not such a simple
position
but reity doesn't really shy away from
end games
and he always sees the beauty of it all
he believes that there
are tactical nuances and interesting
twists
in endings which is actually unique
whenever you check out and i do
encourage everyone who's looking and
watching this
to check out um his puzzles
because they're deep down in the end
game as
reity kind of decided that hey yes it's
an end game but
even end games have like deep set
combinations
hidden there
you can take c4 bishop takes e4 knight
c3
and if you might be asking why well what
is
so special about those well
ratey designed his puzzles without any
computer help obviously
and had to kind of
delve deep into positions to make sure
that there
are no multiple solutions also
he was very well known and is well known
to set up
traps for the reader so you can go
astray
and have a journey of your own finding
the solution
bishop f5 obviously once black gets
the bishop pair it makes a lot of sense
to
uh keep them on the board you do not
want to exchange and that's kind of me
hope
the longer the game goes the more
powerful those bishops get
bishop e3 and here's the moment
where we should try to figure out
how to defend against spillman's
simple threat
it's not that black is already having a
decisive advantage
in fact far from it
i mean there's this idea of b6 but also
a6
both b6 and a6 make a lot of sense
pawn b2 how would you like to
reach the pawn on b2
but even c5 makes some level of sense
but um yeah i mean the big question is
what's the difference between playing c5
here or b6
and there are those little twists and
details
that make or break a good game or
defines
a very strong chess player
now if black would have played c5 the
issue is there's knight b5
hitting there actually even then there's
bishop d3 and
that's not an idea
but the main problem with c5 is it gives
knight d5 a a chance
and if the knight can hop into d5
white can i mean black cannot really
hope for an advantage
right cannot be worse and if bishop e6
then knight b5 would come
a69 d6 and this opposite colored end
game is favorable for white
because of this strong d6 pawn which
will be supported by the bishop
so in any case what reity has to keep in
mind
is not to start exchanging off that dark
squared bishop in fact to keep it so
he understands that the d5 and b5
squares
are all important so he shies away from
c5
he also doesn't play a6 because that
would also weaken
the dark squares on c5 and b6
therefore he played b6 in this position
closing of this bishop and still kind of
controlling the old important
squares on d5 and b5
rook d1 and here comes the big question
whether we should shy away from
exchanges or not
um the reason
you have to ask this from ourselves it's
because
with every exchange you get much much
closer to a draw
so we've got to reason and the viewer
try to figure out would you exchange on
the one or
not is there any benefits of
avoiding it or exchanging
definitely black has these three pawns
three versus two
on the queen side but white has a
majority on the king side so it's not
at all uh a clear clear-cut
decision it doesn't make it easy i think
the position is still very much
complex
because it is saying exchanging on d1
gives away the file so don't like
that on principle i will play h6 and
then
see what y does but perhaps bishop d7
so one of the key things when you're
trying to realize an
advantage is not to become
too passive if you go bishop d7 yes
you avoid exchanging the rooks but
you're
actually kind of putting your pieces
back
not to mention of the fact that white
knight can
slalom to e4 knight e4
and knight d6 and as we talked about
that
before there is knight d6 if we have to
take with this bishop on d6 we can't
really even dream of
winning this game which what uh
reity is clearly dreaming of so going
back with the bishop
does accomplish not exchanging
but would be a little bit too passive to
work
i see bishop b4 does put some pressure
on the position
but i'm not sure if i see your
idea behind it because as i mentioned we
don't want to have an opposite colored
bishop ending
well you do create an island but
islands are cool and islands are even
cooler
when they're opposite colors it's not
at all when for black
in fact it's very close to draw in this
case
so we did mention bishop moves either
trying to press on the c3 knight
or just try to avoid exchanges
the question is in the long run
what is black should be aiming for what
will be
the meta for this game
rook d3 is a very interesting idea
rook d3 i'm
trying to keep the rook there and then
also prepare the rook
rook d3 is by the way a very typical
grand master move these days
um you are offering the
exchange of rooks on the prerequisite
that you actually help and put my bishop
to a better square
which is very important and that's
one of the ways to get a position better
inch by
inch now reity decides to take it
anyways
rook takes d1 rook takes d1
rook d8
so actually reity decides to go for the
exchange
but that means that he has kind of an
inherent
faith in this position
why does reidy
have a hope for an advantage
chat viewers what do you think what
could be the reason he believes
even though the rooks are off he can
still win this game
well black has the bishop there
right black has a bishop bear
and that's one thing but the bishop
nearby in itself
isn't necessarily enough
bishops and hanging pawns not
quite sure what you mean there giovanni
so take six
black kid clearly has some advantage
because of the bishops but that wouldn't
be enough
it actually has to do with the three to
two
on the other side of the board
and thankfully for raytheon this is by
the way
very much berlin type of position
this e pawn is sort of over advanced
if it would be on e4 probably spillman
wouldn't have trouble holding this
position
but as the pawn is already on e5 it's
more of a target
and it's much much harder for rudolph to
actually maneuver around
king f1
king f1 is a great move
so here we've got to improve our pieces
how should we do that
current candidates king f8
bishop e6 what else
what else would be an idea
well checking doesn't really help it
actually would help someone
but not black because the king would
walk into the center
well a5 a5 is an interesting idea
but your a pawn has a duty right now it
has a duty of defending the b-pawn
if you start pushing it these pawns
become
progressively more and more weak
one of the idea could be bishop c7
going after that one so f6 is a natural
move
and a good move at that yanai but the
thing is
if you go f6 you would sort of start
exchanging
which naturally trends towards
a draw not a win so if you're trying to
win
it's a better strategy to keep as much
pieces
piece on the board as possible so in
this sense i like the suggestion of
bishop c7
it wasn't played by richard ritty
but it actually makes sense sort of
provoking f4
not only do you provoke f4 but
eventually
now you could build a fortress in
berlin style just going h5 and
holding and halting the plan
of white he actually went king f8
and i do think bishop c7 is just as good
but probably reity felt that there's
nothing wrong with bringing the king in
now
also notice bringing in the king now
is much much better than pushing the a
pawn not that the a pawn push is bad
but um after the king comes closer
it gains in strength so king f8
here now he goes bishop c7 tries to
attack the spawn
f4 king e8
king f3 and here comes the
aforementioned
h5 controlling the g4 square now this
play what we see now from rey t
maybe wouldn't open any eyes because
we've seen
these berlin ideas recently but again
just a reminder
this is sort of the late
19 10 14
times so it's still early in history
so still before world war
ii mind you and reity already knows
what he's supposed to be doing
knight e4 okay so knight e4
is actually a great move by uh rudolph
spillman
and here we've got to figure out what is
rudolph spielman
really after with this move so first off
we have to identify
our opponent's plans to actually react
to them
so it's not that bishop c7 the idea of
attacking the e5 pawn
was decisive but is a step in the right
direction
so what is my trying to do what would be
white's next move
so one of the big moves is indeed knight
d6
so if you just dilly dally play
something like
a5 knight d6 take stakes
and there is zero hope of you winning
this because of the opposite colored
bishop ending
therefore we need to make an idea and
find a move
that avoids this
so it's white not white to move it is
actually
we figured out what white is trying to
do what
is trying to get some knight d6 in there
yes sometimes knight g5 can be annoying
but that's not the main thread the main
threat is
the immediate simplification so we've
got to avoid that one
king d7 sounds good enough
however reity decided to go bishop e6
and there is like one distinct
difference between bishop e6
and king d7 and that is that this one
immediately threatens to take the apon
fisher style
even though this has been played
roughly 50 years before fischer which
is scary if you think about that
so bishop e6 bishop takes a2
is on the map clearly because the bishop
could waltz out
after the capture so it's not something
that uh white can underestimate
a3 and again it seems like there's
nothing special going on
but ratey spots an idea
and a very very very nasty move
so let's try to find reity's next
move it's not
like it's not
really decisive but puts a lot of
pressure on
white's position
bishop d5 for one it stops this idea of
knight d6
second of all it puts a pin
on this king on f3 by the way
you might have asked what about knight
d6
so with knight d6 actually black would
have a choice
black could even consider taking now
i said before that these are draw
while uh these are drawn but if one
manages to
get the d6 pawn or start pushing
three to one advantage on the other side
there are some hopes for winning
but even if
this doesn't appeal to reity he could go
king d7
and set up this double attack
but anyways um rudolph spinlin played
a3 bishop d5 so
bishop d5 is nice and puts a lot of
pressure
on that king and knight but
again still it begs the question what
would be
black's plan right now so let's look for
some plans
because it's key even in the end game to
have an idea of what you're looking for
so look for plans look for ways
of further improving this position
for black
f5 is an interesting idea trying to
force
the issue but as we said earlier on
we don't necessarily want to force
trades even if it's beneficial for us
because the more exchanges happen the
more likely
we are going to have to acquiesce for a
draw
g6 is a bit more of a defensive
move in nature a jmac not a bad move
but it's not a plan that would further
our goal
so let's try some long-term plans and
for long-term plans we have to identify
which piece of ours is sort of left
out of the play so
the bishop on d5 of course is doing a
great job
pressing that king and pressing the
knight
but what other pieces we have that don't
really contribute
to the final goal of winning
so we can argue definitely that it's the
bishop is there anything else that we
could improve upon
it's again sort of measuring up
which is more important in just a hint
there is another piece that is not ideal
and it's the king it's mostly the king
that
needs to have an idea where it goes to
now i see king e7 suggested but there is
another move
that sort of has the same purpose
but in fact has another layer
of idea and ideas behind that one
so there's a difference between going
king e7
or going king d7 what could be that
subtle difference between going e7 or d7
imani is saying it is nearer to the
queen side
okay but first of what does king e7 kind
of achieve
so what is the basic idea we have
don't forget never forget your original
threats
and if you remember your threats you
will never forget of what you're looking
to
get in the future
well the king is actually trying to walk
up
to f5 if we could get the king up to f5
we would be winning this knight
because of that pin
king e7 wouldn't be
easy to meet because anytime you would
push the pawn
this bishop on c7 would snipe down the e
pawn but okay let's see what
spielman does he goes bishop d4
for that exact reason so if we would go
king d7 there's potentially f5
and now white gets active enough might
even get some chances of his own
so therefore here
righty plays c5 pushes the bishop back
bishop c3 g6 and this is what we talked
earlier on
white builds i mean there is this white
square blockade
working in the position
and just like in many berlin positions
it's very difficult to deal with
and even though white has like a clear
majority on the
king side the bishops sort of holding
them up
king e3 and now he goes king d7
and i really like king d7 in this
position because
it kind of winks in both directions
just like in football or soccer
as it's well known in america
it's better to be ambiguous with your
plans
and if you're looking on both directions
then never know which way you're going
that's why king d7 is so much better
than king e7
because in that case it's blindingly
obvious that veity would go king e6 king
f5
here it can actually can go the other
direction on the queen side
and with the majority of three
versus two there is a good hope of
winning that
so g3 and now again
talking about improvement we already
improved our king
but there is one more piece that we
haven't improved
which one is that
which one is that so
well yeah they can give that check but
we can go king c6 and we get a
very active king for that so yeah you
can go here
when i go king c6 take six
and with that extra pawn majority on
this side of the board
even if you go a four i can go a6 and b5
so by all means this is very comfortable
for black a better king than this one
might even threaten to just
run it down to through c4 and b3
and there is some ample chances of
winning this
and even if it's not winning it is clear
that it's black who is
pressing for the win so g3 was played
but here it was very important to decide
and realize that the other guy that's
not doing too much is this bishop on
c7 so reity just reroutes it
goes bishop d8 knight d6
bishop e7 king d3
and now they're going to have this
standoff
actually black is not going to take that
because opposite colored
endings are usually drawn
so but reity believes that he has more
than that so he goes a6
king e3 now this is the critical moment
for us to decide which direction are we
going to go for
of course taking on d6 still is very
drawish so
not going to help us too much so we've
got to decide
which way should we go if you want to
win this game
so jmac is saying queen sign okay why
would you go queen side
excuses asking i looked at bishop d8 but
is it really nicer to
have the bishop on the e7 than c7 well
maybe it's not pretty but in chess
a bishop doesn't really have to be too
attractive
as long as it's useful and if anything
this bishop is
very useful as it sort of puts pressure
on both directions
both on the king side both on the queen
side and
if your piece is multi-purpose then you
really can't ask more from that piece
and if you think that bishop was better
on c7 not
really because it was sort of just
firing at
pawns that were already kind of
protected
so i do believe that the maneuver by
reity is
superior than just leaving the bishop on
c7
so and in these type of positions
um you've got to realize what
is the benefits and what the bishop
bishop pair wants likes so what type of
positions
chat and dear viewers does the bishops
like the most
so exquisite says king c6 is my move
here
we did kappa blanca and kappa blanca
plays three versus two
definitely an option definitely an
option
so bishops want open positions
open diagonals at the moment our bishop
on e7
someone mentioned that it's not that
pretty and okay i can agree
it's not the most attractive bishop you
can find
in fact the most attractive one is on
the five
chillin and sort of lording down the
board
which is cool but um
we really don't exert too much pressure
on the all important
c4 b4 and a4 squares and if you want to
open up the position
we have to have some influence on that
direction
so if we can't open up on the queen side
what other options do we have
well you can try g5 but is that the only
option we have
the only problem we have at age 4 is if
we go h4 they don't have to react to us
they can let's say pass
and even if we take exchanges doesn't
really
further our agenda
exchanges are not good enough
jana is asking what can e6 and then f6
be an idea so if you go king e6 and f6
would that open up the position just a
little bit
so vinayak is asking is f6 the best
yes or no so the beautiful part of chess
is that there are multiple answers
it can be great and it can also
have some downsides too so there's
pluses and minuses
in playing f6 right here or
avoiding it but it's never like a
clear-cut answer
whether that's great or not especially
in strategic positions of course
if it would be like a tactic smealy
yes you could tell if f6 is terrible
or if it's great but in end games
oftentimes
it's again a bit ambiguous so here
actually reity played king e6
in fact keeping it even more ambiguous
king e6 and the benefit of these moves
are that it doesn't show their hand
in some very prominent card games
you do not want to show your intentions
nor the direction of your play king e6
is sort of played in the same way
he's activating his king but he's not
telling you if he's going to play g5 or
f6
he's saying it's your turn you can
decide to react whichever way you want
but i'm not going to show you
my cards just yet king d3
and we would be tempted to play f6 here
but
here comes richard reity's genius he
says
no i am going to make sure that all
of my pawns are defended
so what did richard reaty play here
in this very position
waiting for a right mistake not
necessarily
but um reity is still very much open
not to tell what he's hoping to do so
bishop d8
and this is the move
that doesn't look and doesn't strike too
inspiring
however it is a prophylactic move by
nature
he makes sure this pawn is defended
let's say if black will play f6 then
there is this move of knight c8
hitting this pawn hitting this bishop
and then there is this move
e takes f6 sort of
diminishing and annoying all the efforts
that reity could have not necessarily
losing for black but he cannot hope for
an advantage
so here bishop d it is a very strong
move
because it sort of circumvents
this idea of knight c8 and prepares this
f6 move
instead
and i can tell you personally whenever i
stream i try to look for ideas such as
this
and i can tell you i was inspired by
reity and his prophylaxis
he does everything in his hands
to make sure that there is no funny
business going on and
uh spielman doesn't have a way to
trick him so bishop d8
makes sense and yeah it's very inspiring
so no wonder
um i try to look for this myself
whenever i play online
so bishop d8 bishop d2 and
when rudolph spielman is sort of
hesitating
and showing the hands then he goes f6
and now as the bishop moved away
then there's this move f6 again as i
mentioned before
this reminds me more of a card game than
a chess game
ratey kept it as unclear as
possible by not really showing the
intentions or his true intentions
and now he sort of
made spillman make an on forced error by
this move of bishop d2
and already he is getting close there
bishop c3 f takes e5
and you can already see that he made
some progress
after xc5 is
one other alternative he goes bishop
takes e5
iman is asking aren't you supposed to
play
on your majority side
um well yes
but as i talked about you are trying to
play for your advantages
and you're playing for the advantage of
your bishop pair
plus the three plus two
and now he goes b5 and again this
is kind of this slow maneuvering kind of
reminds me of the greatest
end game players out there he is in no
rush
to tell his intentions and he just
slowly strengthens his positions first
and what is kind of unique here is that
first he kind of
resolved the issue of the bishop bear it
was more of a closed position
still is a little bit close this bishop
doesn't feel too happy
but if it could go behind those pawns
black would be practically winning
that's why it's so
important that he could pull back his
bishops
a little bit like gotta komski
katakomski was very good in end games
at a very young age and he was a master
of
pulling his bishops away like pulling
this bishop away
so it's kept for the later part of the
game so we've been like
uh playing a couple of moves like 10 12
moves
and there were many many dangerous
moments where it was in danger
of being exchanged but reiki made sure
that
it is withdrawn and it cannot be
exchanged so he kept the bishops
and now the position is opening up
knight e8 bishop b7
king c3 bishop b6 look at that
he's reorganizing his pieces and as i
mentioned
he might be threatening ideas of c4
bishop g1 right g7
king d5 note that the basic rules of
endgame
still matter if he can he will
activate his king bring it to the center
and then activate those bishops
98 c4
owning the most important square the
bishop d4 move is not possible
and bishop g1 is on the agenda
h3 bishop f2 g4
and this is another critical moment
should we take on a g4 or should we
avoid that exchange
and a good point by exquisite yes the
king is sort of cut off
but if you go this direction meaning the
king's side
the queen side will be weak if it stays
on the queen side then
there are problems on the king side
we should avoid the exchange
so whenever you're playing an end game
you always need to find a target
it's not enough to have a bishop there
sometimes it's not even enough
to have a majority on one side
but if you would have two targets in a
position that usually is enough to win
the game
what would be a perfect target uh for
reity
to generate in this position
exquisite is saying h4 there's an
interesting idea
avoiding the exchange but does it really
create a target for the future
but it actually does and that is exactly
what reity plays
he goes h4 and now there is a potential
target on h3
with a potential passer on the h file
which can be super useful at the end of
the day
knight f6 king e6 and we have our target
while this king does have to treat and
be careful
with the three versus two and notice
how he slowly slowly outplays his
opponent
not h7 bishop g2
tightening the grip knight g5 king d5
bishop c3 bishop g3
he's getting closer and closer
and once he smokes out that knight
this end game is very close to be just
winning
f5 takes takes bishop f4
and now it is collapsing
because if you go bishop d2 there is
takes
takes king e5 and the pawn
falls while the h pawn is falling as
well
so here spielman goes for the desperado
bishop takes here bishop h6
bishop d2 here bishop c3
king e6 and now we get into the end game
phase
as actually reity has accomplished
to get a very very very strong grip
on the position he's winning two
important pawns
and he's gonna have pass pawns on both
sides
which is key whenever you're playing
opposite colored bishop endings and
actually the biggest tragedy
for spielman is
that bishop f2 would win the pawn but
this king is just unfortunately placed
if you go here black can just check you
and go h3
retaining the two pawn advantage
bishop c8 king b4 king e6
again ambiguous the king can walk
to f5 that also can go king d5
and again that kind of puts pressure on
the opponent
and they'll have to decide what happens
next king c5
h3 very close to promoting
king f5 a4
king g4 and if the king gets to g2
it's just game over a b
a b king takes king f3 and again this
shows
this is the precision of
the player named richard ratey he's not
afraid of nothing he knows he can go and
defend
the c pawn from behind is no way you'll
lose that pawn
and if you win that bishop that is of
course a clear-cut win
for black bishop h2 bishop b8
bishop e6 obviously defending you cannot
give up
both pawns in that case it's a draw but
after bishop e6 it is game over
because you have to give up that bishop
in order to stop promotion king c3
king c2 king f2 and rudolf
spielmann resign so i really hope you
guys
enjoyed this lecture on how to
kind of milk an advantage that is
seemingly so
little yet weighty makes it look
so much and so easy
first off preserving the bishop there
then
opening up the position pushing a little
bit on the queen side and then
with a southern sudden switch going over
to the king side
and just in time to wrap it up
and win the game on a single tempo
so it was hinging on one tempo even
though reity was
absolutely brilliant in this engage
so really hope you enjoyed this lecture
and i hope to see you guys in the future
on other streams this stream and
other lectures next week and